[Música]
quem de vocês realizou o primeiro sonho
que vocês tinham teve alguém aí que
realizou o primeiro sonho que teve na
vida
pois é eu gosto sempre de fazer essa
pergunta porque eu não realizei o
primeiro sonho que eu tinha muita gente
nos fala que pra gente realizar nossos
sonhos
depende só de esforço e eu sinceramente
não concordo com essa afirmação
eu dediquei muita energia tentando me
tornar um jogador de futebol e não
conseguir
e aí tanta energia dedicada a um
segmento da nossa vida acaba faltando
energia para outros que meu boletim
ficava maravilhoso igual esse da foto
todo vermelho minha mãe sempre muito
animada quando recebia minhas notas não
sabia mais o que fazia se continuava me
apoiando meu sonho
você então me falava filho acho que é
melhor você tomar conta da escola porque
a coisa não está muito boa não
e aí sempre nessas decisões eu
aprendendo coisas de uma nova trajetória
que eu decidi pra minha vida eu me
bahrein um conceito do eduardo saverin
que o brasileiro que estudou em harvard
junto com mark zuckerberg foi um dos
fundadores do facebook e um conceito que
tem me ajudado muito empreendedor os
meus novos sonhos
o eduardo saverin não fala que para a
gente entender um pouco mais de
aceleração que é o que a gente busca
para nossa vida todo mundo que acelerar
acelerar profissionalmente acelerar
pessoalmente e ele fala que para a gente
entender um pouco mais disso a gente tem
que falar sobre tecnologia e sobre os
ciclos passados que a gente já viveu de
inovação
então a gente vai pensar na primeira e
na segunda revolução industrial que
foram basicamente a invenção dos motores
a vapor e depois o aprimoramento dos
motores a vapor das inovações mecânicas
e aí a gente veio para a segunda para a
terceira era de inovações que foi a
revolução científica que serviu como
base para a era da computação pessoal
é o mais interessante que a gente
consegue perceber nesses primeiros
títulos é que novas tecnologias chegavam
sempre para substituir e não utilizar
tecnologias passadas
então a gente vê as tecnologias
mecânicas substituídas inovações a vapor
e assim por diante
depois desses circos surgiu os
computadores pessoais com isso apareceu
à internet ea internet trouxe
conectividade conectividade que por sua
vez fez com que bilhões de dispositivos
móveis estivessem espalhados nas mãos
das pessoas ao redor do mundo inteiro
esses dispositivos móveis fizeram com
que algumas empresas surface nessa onda
de conectividade internet por exemplo
facebook google foram empresas que
aproveitaram desse ciclo
depois disso a gente veio pra ela da
mobilidade levando até inteligência
artificial porque quando surgiu
mobilidade tanto dispositivos na mão de
todo mundo
começou assim a acontecer uma explosão
dos dados que a sociedade tinha só de
2014 até 2016 foram gerados 9 vezes mais
dados do que haviam sido gerados antes
na história da humanidade
e aí surgiu a grande pergunta o que
fazer com tantos dados e o mais
interessante disso tudo é que nesses
ciclos posteriores de inovação
o padrão mudou as tecnologias não chegam
mais para substituir e inutilizar
tecnologias passadas
ela chega para empilhar uma sobre as
outras e é isso que gera aceleração
plataforma sobre plataformas é igual a
aceleração
vamos tomar como exemplo facebook
facebook foi uma tecnologia empilhadas
sobre dispositivos móveis
demorou quatro anos para atingir 100
milhões de usuários que já é super
rápido mas o civil que foi um jogo
empilhado sobre o facebook demorou
apenas dois meses para atingir os mesmos
100 milhões de usuários e o porquê disso
porque eles aproveitaram da base de
dados que o facebook já tinha criado e
com isso eles conseguiram gerar
aceleração
mas o que eu fico mais feliz de saber é
que isso não é um padrão apenas de
tecnologia e muito menos só de produtos
isso a gente pode trazer também para a
nossa vida pessoal
nós como pessoas
interagimos com plataformas o tempo
inteiro
nós estamos estudando em universidade
que podem ser plataformas de aceleração
e nós somos plataformas que nos
empenhamos sobre essas outras
plataformas
então se a gente conseguir entregar bons
resultados onde a gente passa a gente
pode aproveitar desses picos de
aceleração
porque por exemplo que uma universidade
pode servir como uma plataforma de
aceleração
vamos tomar como exemplo a universidade
de columbia
a universidade de colúmbia fica em nova
york foi fundado em 1754 já formou
vários presidentes dos estados unidos
theodore roosevelt barack obama e que
tem 300 anos quase de crescimento em
conhecimento em oportunidades
é uma faculdade que está no epicentro
dos negócios que a nova york é uma
universidade também que já formou vários
dos maiores pensadores empreendedores é
que a humanidade já viu entre eles maior
investidor da história que é o a rebate
não se imagina a possibilidade de ser
acelerado por uma plataforma do tamanho
da universidade de columbia
isso é fantástico né só que muitas vezes
nosso sonho é muito grande mas a gente
não tem tudo o que é necessário para
para passar por determinadas plataformas
por exemplo imagina que vocês como eu
eu não quero aqui simplesmente mostrar
que o desempenho pior do que uma criança
de cinco anos porque isso é verdade já
está mostrado no desenho mas imaginem
que vocês assim como eu desenhar um
sonho de estudar na universidade de
columbia
por que vocês acreditam que essa é uma
plataforma que seria interessante para o
seu futuro empreendedor de sucesso que é
o que você almeja mas infelizmente no
momento que você está querendo ir à
colômbia seu histórico acadêmico é igual
ao que eu tinha quando abandonou o
futebol histórico acadêmico muito fraco
essa plataforma é teoricamente
impossível você entrar
só que a parte mais feliz é que aí você
pode se aproveitar das outras
plataformas que podem te ajudar no que
você já tem o próprio criador russell
tem uma frase que eu adoro que é fácil
que você pode com que você tem no lugar
onde você está
eu era um empreendedor de uma empresa
que estava crescendo a viva açúcar que
eu fundei junto com meu irmão era
empresa que estava crescendo então me
trazia outras oportunidades
com isso eu me aproximei da plataforma
endeavour que reúne alguns dos
empreendedores mais brilhantes do país
e nessa plataforma eu conheci muita
gente boa que me ajudou a crescer dentro
do meu negócio subir de patamar
depois wendel fui também depois de muito
esforço muita é luta comecei a ser
melhorado pelo alex costa que é fundador
de uma das maiores empresas do brasil e
que me ajuda
freqüentemente com atitudes o alê costa
é uma plataforma que me acelerou também
em direção aos meus sonhos
fui selecionado é convidado pela câmara
de comércio americana amcham para ser
presidente do comitê de gestão
empresarial da ram e uma outra
plataforma que tem várias empresas
legais que me ajudam bastante com o
networking com conhecimento super legal
e que é importante perceber com isso
à medida que as coisas foram acontecendo
eu fui subindo meu nível e conseguindo e
cada vez mais perto de um próximo
objetivo e eu não estou falando aqui que
é garantido que eu tenha sucesso
tentando aplicar para a colômbia que
vocês tenham sucesso tentando aplicar
para as coisas que fazem o coração de
vocês cantarem como diria o steve jobs
mas outro pensamento do theodore
roosevelt que eu adoro é que dá quando a
gente tem um sonho grande não importa se
lá na frente a gente vai sentir o gosto
do sucesso
o que importa é que pelo menos a gente
sinto gosto do fracasso porque assim nós
não nos misturar emos com as almas
tímidas de quem não tentou correr atrás
dos seus objetivos e é o que eu busco
pra minha vida então pode ser que vocês
não consigam estudar na universidade de
colúmbia pode ser que eu não consigo
estudar na universidade de colômbia mas
pode ser tanto
em que aconteça a mesma coisa que
aconteceu comigo quarta-feira quando
recebi essa carta dizendo que eu fui
aprovado para estudar na unb e da
universidade colúmbia uma coisa que era
praticamente impossível para mim então a
mensagem final que eu deixo para vocês
depois de conseguir realizar isso que
era um sonho e que foi muito difícil
baseado no meu histórico acadêmico e
profissional é sigam em direção aos
sonhos de vocês vai e se de medo vai com
medo 'briga' tamo junto
[Aplausos]
[Música]